ASSEMBLY HIRED EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER-
NOTICING THE LACK OF A QUORUM
WE WILL. START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. WELCOME TO THE
FINAL SENATE BILL HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
WHETHER YOU ARE HERE IN PERSON
WATCHING VIRTUALLY RUN THE
PHONE LINES I'M GRATEFUL THAT
YOU HAVE JOINED US HERE ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
PLEASE NOTE THAT THE SPEAKER
HAS APPOINTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PHILLIP CHEN TO REPLACE MEMBER.
WELL AND THAT IS FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GEN. I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO EXTEND A WARM WELCOME BACK
TO THE STAFF AND TO THE PUBLIC
TO THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
ADDITIONALLY IN FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY THIS COMMITTEE HIRED A
NEW CONSULTANT. ALLEN MONROY
BUT DUE TO THE PANDEMIC SHE'S
NOT BEEN ABLE TO ATTEND IN
PERSON. TO THE HEARING OF THIS
COMMITTEE UNTIL TODAY. A WARM
WELCOME TO OUR- PER THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR FILE ITEM ONE S.
B. FIVE FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
STEPHEN GLAZER HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM THE COMMITTEE HEARING. I
WILL NOT GO OVER SOME KEY
ELEMENTS OF THE STRUCTURE OF
TODAY'S HEARING. PLEASE NOTE
THAT MASTER REQUIRED TO BE WORN
AT ALL TIMES BY EVERYONE HERE
FOR THIS HEARING ON THE CHAMBER
FLOOR. PLEASE BE SURE THAT
YOU'RE WEARING YOUR MASK IN THE
APPROPRIATE WAY WITH YOUR MOUTH
AND NOSE FULLY COVERED. WE HAVE
A FEW THERE'S DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. ON
THE CHAMBER FLOOR BY TELEPHONE
TELEPHONE BY THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED ON
THE NORTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL.
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING WHEN
SHE FINISHED TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. THOSE WILL
WITNESSES USING THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED ON
THE NORTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM AND ALSO QUESTION.
THESE WITNESSES. THERE MAY BE A
SLIGHT DELAY FROM THE STREAM
FROM THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION SO PLEASE BE PATIENT.
WE WILL ALSO BE USING AN A. T.
AND T. MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON THE ON
THE BILL. THERE MAY BE A
SLIGHTLY DELAYED SO AGAIN I ASK
THAT ALL INVOLVED REMAIN
PATIENT. THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE
CALLING NUMBER FOR THE HEARING.
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU
COULD ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV OR MONITOR SCREEN.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. YOU'RE CALLING THEN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICE TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
SURE TO MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN
YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING. IS ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOUR LEAD
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF. UNTIL
YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. ADDITIONALLY PLEASE
NOTE THAT THE GUIDELINE FOR
BILLS HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE
IS TO ALLOW TESTIMONY FROM TO
LEAD WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK FOR NO NO MORE AT THE TWO
MINUTES EACH. STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS AND ENTITIES NEITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION WILL
BE ALLOWED TO GIVE TESTIMONY
FOR NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
WHEN I CALL FOR TWEETERS. THE
MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIESIN THE TWEENER
CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT. METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE
TO RESPOND TO ROLL CALL ASK A
QUESTION PROVIDE A COMMENT AND
ASK YOU TO RAISE YOUR MATT
MICROPHONES OF STAFF CAN
ACTIVATED WHEN YOU ARE.
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. ALSO IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE STAND AND FACE
THE MICROPHONE WAS SPEAKING TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
AND CAN BE RECORDED. FOR
AUTHORS OF THE BILLS EACH
MEMBER PRESENTED TODAY WILL
PROVIDE AN OPENING AND CLOSING
STATEMENT. YOUR TO LEAD
WITNESSES WILL BE ANNOUNCED BY
THE CHAIR AND I AS I PREVIOUSLY
STATED WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
PROVIDE. TESTIMONY. AND NOW IF
BATUM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL. MEDINA PRESIDENT
MEDINA HERE CHOI CHOI HERE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HERE BLOOM
BLOOM HERE GABRIEL. IRWIN IRWIN
HERE KILEY LEVINE LEVINE HERE
LOW SANTIAGO CHEN CHEN HERE
WEBER. WEBER HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU. SO BEFORE
GOING ON TO THE BILLS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE. TWO BILLS ON
CONSENT THEY ARE AS FOLLOWS
FILE ITEM TWO SB FOUR SIXTEEN
AND FILE ITEM SEVEN S. B.
TWENTY SIX ZERO UP WE HAVE A
MOTION- FROM DOCTOR CHOI. A
SECOND BY DOCTOR RUMBULA. MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MEDINA HI MEDINA HI
CHOI CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN.
IRWIN I HIGHLY LEVINE. LEVINE I
LOW SANTIAGO JAN. CHEN I WEBER
WEBER HI. VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO.
EIGHT ZERO THE CONSENT ITEMS
ARE PASSED AND WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT NOTED NOTE NOTING THAT-
SENATOR NEWMAN IS HERE WE WILL
BEGIN WITH S. B. FOUR FORTY TWO
FILE ITEM FIVE BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. SENATOR NEWMAN WHEN
YOU'RE READY PLEASE PROCEED-
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MR
IT SAID THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
TO YOUR HOUSE- I AM HERE BEFORE
YOU TODAY TO PRESENT SB FOUR
FORTY TO A BILL THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA- ABLE TO SMOOTHLY
TRANSITION FROM AT LARGE
ELECTIONS TO DISTRICT BASED
ELECTIONS WITHOUT ENCOURAGING
INCURRING THE PERSPECTIVE COSTS
AND DELAYS OF THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT LAWSUIT
DURING THAT PROCESS. IN RECENT
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE IS
ENCOURAGED POLITICAL
SUBDIVISIONS SUCH AS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADOPT DISTRICT
BASED ELECTIONS WHILE
SIMPLIFYING THE PROCESS FOR
DOING SO SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THE CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS
ACT IN TWO THOUSAND ONE TO
PROMOTE GREATER REPRESENTATION
IN EQUITY IN ELECTIONS. MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED OF
CALIFORNIA'S ONE THOUSAND
THIRTY SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE SWITCHED FROM AT LARGE
ELECTIONS TO DISTRICT BASED
ELECTIONS UNDER CURRENT LAW
EDUCATION CODE SECTION FIVE OH
ONE NINE ALLOWS COUNTY
COMMITTEES THAT OVERSEE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ORGANIZATION. TO
ESTABLISH TRUSTEER AREA
ELECTIONS IN A PROMPT AND
INCLUSIVE PROCESS UNFORTUNATELY
FOR REASONS HAVING TO DO WITH
HOUSE AREA STATE STATUTES AND
CODES INTERSECT THE CURRENT
CODE MAKES AN EXCEPTION FOR
SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE GOVERNED BY
THE CHARTER OF THE CITY. OR A
COUNTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS DURING
THIS DESCRIPTION ARE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO PUT ANY
ORDINANCE AND ESTABLISHING
TRUSTEE AREA ELECTIONS TO THE
ELECTORS IN THE DISTRICT WHICH
OFTEN RESULTS IN AN OFFICIAL
ELECTION AND SOMETIMES AN OFF
CYCLE ELECTION AT SUBSTANTIAL
EXPENSE TO THE LOCALITY. IN
PRACTICE AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CAN BYPASS THIS REQUIREMENT BY
SECURING A WAIVER FROM THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION THIS
EXTRA STEP HOWEVER STILL LEADS
TIME AN ADDITIONAL COST OF THE
ADOPTION OF TRUST YEAR
ELECTIONS AND THIS DELAY HAS
RESULTED IN FURTHER AT LARGE
ELECTIONS THAT ARE TECHNICALLY
IN VIOLATION. OF THE CVR ACT
THESE UNNECESSARY COMPLEXITIES
CAN RIP CAN RESULT IN COSTLY
LITIGATION AS WELL AS
SUBSEQUENT UNLAWFUL AT LARGE
ELECTIONS THAT PERPETUATE THE
DILUTION OF MINORITY VOTES IN
VIOLATION OF EITHER THE SPIRIT
OR THE LETTER OF THE CVR RIGHT
AS AN EXAMPLE JUST YESTERDAY
THE SENATE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
ON WHICH I SIT HEARD ASSEMBLY
EDGE CHAU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO'S AB THROUGH FORTY WHICH
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA. TO SUBMIT A PROPOSAL
OF A SPECIAL ELECTION TO REMOVE
FROM THE CITY'S CHARTER. ALL
REFERENCES TO THE ALHAMBRA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THEREBY
SOLVING THE SAME PROBLEM
THROUGH VERY DIFFERENT MEANS SB
FOUR FORTY TWO FIXES THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM. BY ALLOWING
ORDINANCES APPROVING A PROPOSAL
TO ESTABLISH TRUSTEE AREAS. TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY UPON
ADOPTION WITHOUT THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL ELECTION. TO AFFIRM
APPROVAL UNDER THE PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL THIS WOULD APPLY
TO ALL ELECTIONS FOR GOVERNING
BOARD MEMBERS. MORE THAN A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DAYS
FOLLOWING ITS ADOPTION. WITH
THESE CHANGES AS BEFORE FOR TWO
WILL STREAMLINE THE TRANSITION
PROCESS WILL ELIMINATING
ADDITIONAL COSTS. TO TAXPAYERS
RESULTING FROM DELAYS IN
PERSPECTIVE LITIGATION THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. AND HAS HAD NO
OPPOSITION THUS FAR MOST
RECENTLY PASSING OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
WITH A SEVEN ZERO VOTE. WITH ME
TODAY VIRTUALLY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS- MACHEL
WARSHAW AND LARRY SHIREY FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE EXPERT WITNESSES
ON THE LINE. SHOULD THERE BE
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS BY THE
COMMITTEE. MICHELLE WARSHAW AND
LARRY SHERRY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER. IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE. I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER ANY TWEETERS.
BACK IN THE GALLERY OR IN THE
CHAMBER. WISHING TO SPEAK. SAY
NINE WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU FOR AND SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FOUR TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO HERE IN SUPPORT. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR NEWMAN THIS IS TONY
CHOI GUERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WERE HAPPILY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN Q. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR FOUR TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE OF AND THEREFORE IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ARE THERE ANY TWEENER
IS ON THE PHONE OR- IN THE
QUEUE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT OF S. A. B. FOUR
FOUR TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND I COMMANDED ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. MOTION BY DOCTOR
RUMBULA SECOND BY MISTER BLOOM-
I HAS OF COURSE OKAY. THIRTY
CHOI THANK YOU CHAIR- AS
SENATOR NEWMAN AYE- FORTY
UNDERSTANDING YOUR INTENT OF
THIS BILL. WITH CHARLIE. WILL
BE A ARE SUPPORTING BUT- I
WONDER- WHY- LEGISLATORS SOUL-
OVER. OF POWERING- THE LOCAL-
RESIDENTS OF. DECISION THROUGH
THEIR OWN- ON BALLOT MEASURES
USUALLY CHARTER CITIES SO WE'RE
HAVE A THERE ARE- CONSTITUENTS
SO TO DECIDE BILLS ON THIS TYPE
OF MATTERS YOUR BILL IS-
THROUGH- WAIVER. OF CERTAIN
ELECTION. AND THERE ARE PROS
AND CONS OF BUT I THINK IN OUR
DEMOCRACY WHERE THE POWER COMES
FROM THE PEOPLE BUT- WE-
LEGISLATORS TO APPEAR TRYING TO
SHORT CUT. ZERO REPRESENTATION
OF THEIR POWER WATER-
PREFERENCES SO HOW WOULD YOU-
IF I VOTED YES ON HOW CAN I
DEFEND MY VOTE SO WHEN I GO
DOWN TO MY DISTRICT. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION OCTOR
CHOICE SO- THE BEST BILL IS
INTENDED TO SIMPLY PLACE THOSE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO CURRY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS. THAT ARE
GOVERNED BY A CITY OR A COUNTY
CHARTER ON THE SAME FOOTING AS
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS IT IN NO
WAY IS IT HAS NO INTENTION OR
EFFECT OF SHIFTING THE POWER OR
EVEN THE PROCESS OF MAKING THE
TRANSITION FROM AT LARGE
ELECTIONS TO DISTRICT ELECTIONS
IN THE THIS IS SIMPLY. A
STREAMLINING BILL- TO PLACE
THOSE DISTRICTS IN THE SAME
POSITION THAT THEY WOULD BE AS
THE OTHER- MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
WHO AT THE TIMEOF MAKING A
DECISION TO SHIFT TO DISTRICT
ELECTIONS UNDER THE TERMS OF
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND ONE. IT LETS THEM
DO THAT IN SCITUATE THAT THEY
ARE NEITHER SUBJECT ADDITIONAL
COSTS- NOR PROSPECTIVE
LITIGATION. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAD A MOTION BY
DOCTOR RUMBLE AS SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK TONIGHT THANK
YOU. I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
NEWMAN FOR PROVIDING THIS BILL
AND CHAMPIONING THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF TWENTY.
ZERO ONE DECISIONS REGARDING
EDUCATION SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
BY REPRESENTATIVES ELECTED FROM
THE NEIGHBORHOODS THEY
REPRESENT. AND THIS IS WHY I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL- MADAM
SECRETARY THE MOTION BEFORE IS
DO PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. AND I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL IRWIN
IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I
LOW SANTIAGO CHEN CHEN I WEBER.
WEBER I'D. THE VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO. EIGHT ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT. DAMES SURE THANK YOU
MEMBERS WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. RIGHT ARM.
GOING BACK IN FILE ORDER. YES
WE'LL GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
THREE BY SENATOR PER TITLE. S.
B.
FOUR FIFTY THREE. SENATOR
TITLE. OKAY. I MEAN FOR SOMEONE.
CENTER MANAGER OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. THE NEXT BILLING FILE
ORDER SB FIVE TWELVE FILE ITEM
FOR- BY SENATOR MEN. I BELIEVE
IS HERE.
SENATOR MAN WELCOME
TO- COMMITTEE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN THANK YOU CHAIR MEDINA
AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND STAFF TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SP FIVE TWELVE WHICH SEEKS TO
REDUCE SOME OF THE BARRIERS
THAT CURRENTLY EXIST IN THE
NEXT UP PROGRAM. WHICH PROVIDES
A COMPREHENSIVE ARRAY OF
SERVICES TO PROMOTE COLLEGE
RETENTION AND AGREE ATTAINMENT
FOR FOSTER YOUTH. THE NEXT A
PROGRAM IS IN PLACE IN FORTY
FIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES
ANNUALLY SERVING TWO THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTHS. CURRENTLY TO
QUALIFY FOR THIS PROGRAM
STUDENTS MUST HAVE BEEN IN
FOSTER CARE AFTER THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN. BE UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX AND BE ENROLLED IN A
MINIMUM OF NINE ACADEMIC UNITS.
WELL THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE FOR
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH RETENTION
DEGREE COMPLETION RATES. THE%
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOUND IN A
REPORT. THAT THERE WERE SEVERAL
BARRIERS PREVENTING MANY OF
THESE WONDERFUL STUDENTS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM.
TO ADDRESS THESE BARRIERS SB
FIVE TWELVE SIX TO DO THE
FOLLOWING. FIRST MODIFY THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM OUT
ENABLE STUDENTS WHO ARE IN
FOSTER CARE AFTER THE AGE OF
THIRTEEN TO PARTICIPATE. SECOND
CREATE FLEXIBILITY AROUND
INCOME REQUIREMENTS FOR
STUDENTS TRANSITIONING FROM
FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT TO SCHOOL.
THIRDS SPECIFYING THAT EXISTING
FUNDS CAN BE USED TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO ENROLLED STUDENTS AS
IF THEY ARE AS THEY ARE
MATRICULATING. FOURTH
CLARIFYING THAT PROGRAM SHOULD
CREATE STREAMLINED SYSTEM FOR
APPLICATION AND ENTRY. FINALLY
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY FOR
PRIORITY ENROLLMENT AT THE UC
CSU NCCC CAMPUSES. BY INCLUDING
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN FOSTER CARE
ON OR AFTER THEIR THIRTEENTH
BIRTHDAY. ALIGNING WITH THE
SAME AGE THRESHOLD USED TO
DETERMINE INDEPENDENT STATUS
WITHIN FASTER. SB FIVE TWELVE
ALLOW US TO BETTER SERVE MORE
OF THIS VULNERABLE POPULATION
OF STUDENTS AN ADDITIONAL
ELEVEN HUNDRED OF THEM WOULD BE
SERVED BY THE NEXT UP PROGRAM.
AND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MORE
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR PRIORITY
ENROLLMENT AND ARE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS SHOULD
THIS BILL PASS. WITH ME HERE
TODAY TESTIFY I'VE DAVID
O'BRIEN FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
AND KAELIN FAN STUDENT AFFECTED
BY THE NEXT A PROGRAM. EIGHTEEN
T. MODERATOR THE FIRST WITNESS
CALLING IN IS DAVID O'BRIEN
VICE CHANCELLOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS. AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. A MISTER BRIAN PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE AND NOTING THAT
GAMES ARE BRIAN VICE CHANCELLOR
FOR GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND WE REALLY JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS MEASURE BROWN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU- FOR
WHAT IS BOTH A VERY CALM AND-
BILL BUT ALSO A MUCH NEEDED.
ICAL ONE FOR OUR STUDENTS WERE
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. WHO AS SENATOR MEN NOTED
OUR SOME OF OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED AND VULNERABLE. IN
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. I WON'T GO INTO
DETAIL ABOUT THE SERVICE IS THE
NEXT STEP PROVIDE BUT THE TYPE
OF THE STATE THAT THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM- ONE SURVEY
SHOWED OVER NINETY NINE PER
CENT OF IDENTICAL FIGURE NEXT
OUT. ACCORDING TO THE PROGRAM
HOW TO HELP THEM ACADEMICALLY
THAT IS JUST. ASTONISHING FIX
THAT- AND- THE STATE AS THE
SENATOR NOTED THE AGE SIXTEEN-
BERRIER IS SOMEWHAT ARBITRARY
AND WE HAVE HAD MANY STAFF
BECAUSE THEY HAD TO TURN AWAY.
IN NEED BECAUSE OF THEIR
STATUTORY CRITERIA THE STUDENT
BEING IN FOSTER CARE ON OR
AFTER THEY TURN AGE SIXTEEN SO
MOVING IT UP EARLIER TO THE AGE
THIRTEEN WILL ALLOW THE PROGRAM
TO REACH MANY MORE STUDENTS. I
THOUGHT THE LINE THE NEXT THAT
WITH OTHER FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAMS THAT USE A SEARCHING
AND REMOVE A BURDEN ON NAFTA
STAFF MAKING IT EASIER TO
PROCESS AND VERIFY STUDENTS
ELIGIBILITY. SO THE NATION
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS AND APPRECIATIVE OF THE
AUTHOR THE SPONSORS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR STUDENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN. DEMANDING CHANGES
THAT AFFECT YOUR SLEEPING
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THEY YOU MISTER OVER. EIGHTEEN
MODERATE THIS WHICH- CALLING IN
IS. MISS KAELIN. STUDENT CITY
CITY COLLEGE. IS FOUND PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU READY. HI MY
NAME IS CAROLINE SAM ALEX
DIDN'T CITY COLLEGE. I AM
DOCTOR WHEN I WAS A FASTER TO
GET THIS ANALYSIS YEARS OLD
ALONG TO MY. FIVE I WHERE
MAINTENANCE. FIVE NINE NINE DR
EIGHT. WHEN I WAS THE IN HIGH
FELT OUT OF- I IN. AND GAVE MY
DOCTOR PARENTS WHO WILL. PEOPLE
WILL CATHOLIC. AND BECAUSE I
WAS THE AGE OF EIGHTY THE TIME
ME I HAD TO. I SUPPORTED MY
OVER IN ORDER TO FINISH SCHOOL
I TO GO COMMUNITY COLLEGE. BUT
SUMMER TWELVE TRYING TO BALANCE
SCHOOL AND WORK THANK A TEACHER
OUT. I GOING TO NOTE AS LAST.
BUT WAS DISH. TO INJURY. I
THOUGHT. YOU KNOW CALLED ACCRA
AGAIN LIVING IN OUT OF MY CAR.
IN A PART WITH MY BIOLOGICAL
MOTHER WHO WITH HER CELL BEING
IS THAT. PASADENA THANK SEVEN
EXCEPT FOR BUT I COULD NOT.
BECAUSE I HAD LESS YOUR THE
**** CARE BEFORE THE OF
SIXTEEN. I MANAGE TO THEM HELP
THEM AGAIN CITY COLLEGE BUT
COULD GREATLY. FROM THAT
THERE'S OF WITH A- THAT THE
STEP PROGRAM AFFORD. MY WHO
ELECT AFTER SIXTEEN GET QUALIFY
FOR THE PROGRAM SHARED SOME OF
THE BEST. WITH LIKE WITHOUT
YOUR AND HE ME- TO PAY FOR SOME
CHECK ALSO. I WOULDN'T WANT IF
I HAD TO LEAVE. DUE TO DUE TO
THE PENN. I HOPE YOU RETURN TO
COLLEGE. A CAREER HEALTH CARE
IF YOU. I THINK SO TO PASS IT
IS ME WHO FACED. POINT CHECK
CALL BECAUSE COULD NOT HAVE
THAT KIND OF. CHAT WITH THE-
AND OTHER THINGS HAVE WHAT THE
SUPPORT NEXT. TO BE SUCCESS.
ARE YOU VOTE YES ON S. FIVE
ONE. THANK YOU. ANY TWEETERS IN
THE BACK OF CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY. C. NINE WILL MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR THERE ANY WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OR IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HUGE STATE SUPPORT ON SB FIVE-
TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND WE WILL BOTH
THE LINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINES
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON COULD MEET
THE ENEMY HOW CALIFORNIA COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATE
ASSOCIATION OR CALIFORNIA COP
THAT IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO THE LINE OF THIRTY TO
YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN MEMBERS MRS ANNA JOHNSON
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
USE- COSTA BUXBAUM SERVICE SB
FIVE TWELVE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
BUSINESS JORDAN ABOUT THE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
AND ACTION A CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL SB FIVE WELL ONLY IN FOR
WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER TO LINE FORTY
THREE YEAR LINES OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS ASHLEY BURCH- I'M WITH
SAN DIEGO CITY COLLEGE AND THEN
NEXT STEP PROGRAM AND MY
SUPPORT I SUPPORT SB FIVE
TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DIMITRI AT THE
WORD NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS NATASHA MAKE
HERE CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. THEN
CALLING SUPPORT AND SB. FIVE
ONE TWO. THANK YOU MEXICO GO TO
LINE OF FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND AFTER NEAR MISSES
MAGGIE RIGHT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB FIVE TWELVE THANK
YOU. THEY GIVE NEXT ABOUT THE
LINE OF THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND THE NEXT STEPS TO
SUPPORT FOR NADER AND I'D LIKE
TO SHARE ME. AT. FIVE THANK YOU
MR CHERRY HAVE NO FOR THEIR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR EITHER
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SAY OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR
ANY OPPOSITION. I MISSED YOUR
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THE MOMENT THANK YOU
MODERATOR OTHER ANY TWEETERS.
AND ANY CLEANERS YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE
KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. DR CHOI. OKAY SENATOR
MAN ARE ARE WE SUPPORTING YOUR
VIDEO- BUT I HAVE A SLIGHT
QUESTION YOUR ESSENCE OF THE
BILL IS SET TO EXPAND THAT
DEFINITION OF OFF FORMER-
FOSTER YOUTH. TO INCLUDE THE
CHILDREN INVOLVED A AND THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM ANYTIME
AFTER THEIR THIRTEENTH BIRTHDAY
WHICH IS A CURRENTLY- SIXTEEN
AND THE ORDER. I WONDER-
EXPANSIONISTS ARE GOOD ABOUT
THE I WONDER HOW YOU HAVE
DETERMINED THAT THE CHIDREN
WHO- UNDER OUR CARE SYSTEM-
AFTER THIRTEENTH ABOUT THE SOUL
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THIS-
INCLUDES A THIRTEEN YEARS OLD
OR FROM FOURTEEN YEARS OLD. I
MEAN NOT TO MY COMMON SENSE IS
THE STAR ANY TIME IN THEIR LIFE
OR- EVEN TEN YEARS OLD TO NINE
YEARS OLD. HOW DOES IT MAKE ANY
DIFFERENCE AWARE THIS UP BEFORE
WHY WHY DO YOU A NEWLY DEFINED
ONLY HALF AFTER THE THIRTEEN
YEARS OLD. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT QUESTION VICE CHAIR-
YOU KNOW AND I THINK THIS IS
MEANT TO BE AN IMPORTANT
INCREMENTAL STEPS RIGHT AS YOU
AS ONE OF THE WITNESSES NOTED
SIX TO THE CARNAGE OF SIXTEEN.
IS SOMEWHAT ARBITRARY- THIRTEEN
MAKES SENSE AND PERHAPS YOU AND
I CAN CONSIDER CO AUTHORING A
BILL THAT EXPANDS THAT DOWN TO
EIGHT ZERO NEXT YEAR IF THAT'S
OF INTEREST- BUT I THINK IT'S
YOU KNOW. KIND OF JUST TAKING
THAT NEXT STEP IN EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM- BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO
REFER TO I THINK MISTER O'BRIEN
TO. GIVE YOU MORE SPECIFICS
HERE. OKAY THAT'S GOOD IDEA.
CAN I ASK PERMISSION ASKED YEAH.
I MISTER BRIAN IF YOU WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THANK YOU- AND THANK YOU
DOCTOR CHOICE FOR THE ASK ONE
QUESTION AND THEN ORDER- I
WOULD JUST KNOW THAT- WE WOULD
AGREE THAT IN CONCEPT IS AN
INCREMENTAL STEP AND CERTAINLY
A CASE CAN BE MADE THAT- THERE
ARE KERN YOUNGER FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH THAT- WHO WERE IN THE
SYSTEM AT ALL AGES- WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM SERVICES SUCH AS
THAT. HOWEVER THERE ARE MANY
OTHER FEDERAL AND STATE
PROGRAMS SERVING KERN IS FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH THE TWO YEARS THE
AGE THIRTEEN CUT OFF FROM- SO
BUILT UP IN LARGE PART HELPS
BRING THE NEXT STEP PROGRAM IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE SORT OF THE
SUITE OF OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE- AND I WOULD ALSO
JUST NOTE YEAH IN RESPONSE TO
THE- THE OTHER QUESTION I
BELIEVE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAD
IT IS. ON OR AFTER THEIR
THIRTEENTH BIRTHDAY SEVEN H.
THIRTEEN WOOD COUNTY BUT WITH
THE QUESTION. THANK YOU MISTER
RYAN. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE-
SEEING NINE CENTER MAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS- AS A FORMER
PROFESSOR IS A CHILD OF
IMMIGRANTS I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND
I'VE LIVE FIRSTHAND. THE
IMPORTANCE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
IN THE SOCIOECONOMIC OUTCOMES
AND I THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL
IT'S A RIGHTEOUS BILL THAT WILL
HELP MANY MANY PEOPLE AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE MINUTE THANK A SENATOR MAN
FOR KEEPING THIS BILL ALIVE IN
THIS YEAR'S LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. AND THANK YOU FOR
FIGHTING TO ENSURE THAT MORE
BARRIERS ARE REMOVED FROM
FOSTER YOUTH. ENABLING THEM TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE NECESSARY
SERVICES WHICH WILL HELP THEM
HAVE BETTER CHANCES FOR
SUCCESS. WHILE IN COLLEGE- NOT
SURE THAT I HAD A MOTION. THE.
MOVED BY DR RUMBULA SECOND BY
DOCTOR CHOI. THIRD BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW- THE MOTION BEFORE
US IS DO PASSED A HUMAN SERVICE
COMMITTEE ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI HI CHOI I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI LUME.
LOOM II GABRIEL IRWIN. IRWIN I
KILEY. LEVINE LEVINE I LOW LOW
I SANTIAGO. CHEN CHEN I WEBER.
WEBER II. THE VOTE IS NINE ZERO
NINE ZERO CENTER MEN YOUR BILL
IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
GO BACK. TO SENATOR- TITLE
CENTER WE GIVE ME A MOMENT.
RIGHT. SO WE ARE BACK TO FILE
ITEM THREE S. B. FOUR FIFTY
THREE. SENATOR TITLE YOU MAY
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS FOR YOUR OCCUPATION
HERE TODAY AND I'M HERE TO
INTRODUCE- S. B. FOUR FIVE
THREE BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THINKING THAT
SHARING COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. SB
FOUR FOUR THREE TAKES A MUCH
NEEDED AND STRATEGIC STEP
TOWARDS ENSURING OUR BIO
SECURITY. CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY REPRESENTS
A FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
FOR THE STATE AND PRODUCES MORE
THAN HALF OF THE NATION'S
FRUITS VEGETABLES AND NUTS.
PATH PAST DISEASE AND
CONTAMINANTS THAT THREATENED
PLANTS AND ANIMALS. BRENT THE
INTEGRITY RELIABILITY
SUSTAINABILITY AND PROVIDED FOR
BOTTOM PROBABILITY OF OUR FOOD
SYSTEMS. LEFT UNCHECKED THEY
CAN ALSO THREATEN OUR OWN
HEALTH. ONE HEALTH IS AN
APPROACH TO HEALTH CARE THAT
RECOGNIZES THAT THE HEALTH OF
PEOPLE IS CLOSELY LINKED TO THE
HEALTH OF ANIMALS AND OF OUR
SHARED ENVIRONMENT THE CDC
ESTIMATES THAT THREE OUT OF
FOUR EMERGING INFECTIOUS
DISEASES AND PEOPLE COME FROM
ANIMALS. CURRENTLY THERE ARE
ONE POINT SIX MILLION
UNDISCOVERED VIRUSES
CIRCULATING IN THE ANIMAL
POPULATION. AND AT LEAST HALF
OF WHICH HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
SPREAD TO HUMANS. SB FOUR FIVE
THREE PUTS CALIFORNIA AND THE
CSU SYSTEM AT THE FOREFRONT OF
RESEARCH ON BIO SECURITY. IN
DOING SO LAYS THE GROUNDWORK TO
BETTER PROTECT OUR STATE AND
THE NATION FROM IMPACTS TO OUR
FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN AND
RECOGNIZES THE LINK BETWEEN THE
HEALTH OF OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
OUR OWN HEALTH. CALIFORNIA THE
CSU AGRICULTURAL INSTITUTE ARE
IDEALLY SITUATED FROM THE DAY
TO CONDUCT THIS RESEARCH WITH
WORLD CLASS RESEARCH CENTERS IN
THE TOP AGRICULTURE PRODUCING
REGIONS IN THE WORLD. AND
ACCESS TO A BROAD CROSS SECTION
OF EXCEPTIONAL PROFESSORS AND
STUDENTS. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
I HAVE A DOCTOR JUST ME BEING A
FAMILY PHYSICIAN FOR
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA. AND A
DOCTOR REYES FOR INTERPUBLIC
HELPED HER CORRECTOR UP FOR
FRESNO COUNTY. THANK YOU
SENATOR OR TITLE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR THE LEAD WITNESS ON
THE LINE FOR S. B. FOUR FIFTY
THREE. IS DOCTOR BAINES A
FAMILY FOR HIS DECISION FROM
BAKERSFIELD DR BAINES PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR
GIVE ME PAIN. I AM A PRIMARY
CARE FAMILY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN
LOCATED IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OF CALIFORNIA AND KERN COUNTY.
THIS PAST YEAR I WAS HONORED TO
HAVE BEEN AUTHORIZED TO MANY
OCCASIONS OF THE POSITION AND
SADLY IT PROVED TO BE. THE
WORST YEAR OF MY LIFE WITH THE
POSITION WITH OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND LIVES LOST IN JUST
OVER A YEAR. THERE ARE MANY
LESSONS LEARNED BADLY LEARN IN
THE HARDEST WAY POSSIBLE. WE IN
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WILL
CARRY THE SCARS OF THE PAST
YEAR WITH US. FOREVER THERE
WILL EVER BE A NORMAL NOW THE
TIME THAT WE NEED TO DO ALL WE
CAN TO STUDY FOR THE RESEARCH
AND BETTER PREPARE COMMUNITIES
FOR THE FUTURE. PROBABLY
NINETEEN. THE ONLY PANDEMIC
THAT CAN ARISE THERE ARE VERY
MANY OTHER ILLNESSES THAT CAN
CRUMBLE OUR SOCIETIES- VALLEY
FEVER IS ONE EXAMPLE OF AN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE THAT
DEBILITATING MY COMMUNITY. I
HAVE PUBLISHED. RESEARCH AND M.
AND ADVOCATE FOR VALLEY FEVER-
PATIENTS THAT I TREAT ON A
DAILY BASIS- THERE IS MUCH WORK
THAT WE NEED TO BE DOING- NOW
THE TIME TO DO IT NOW THE TIME
THAT WE NEED TO PUT. A LOT OF
AWARENESS AND PUBLICATION
AROUND WHAT WE WENT THROUGH IN
ADDITION TO- INCREASING OUR-
OUR RESEARCH FOR THE FUTURE TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY- WHAT
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS.
WHY WHY RE FORCED TO SHUT DOWN
OUR ENTIRE ECONOMY FURTHER
DOCTOR MEETING AFTER TO HELP
YOUR BY LOSS OF JOBS AND HEALTH
CARE INSURANCE WHY. THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE AND
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
INCREASE RESEARCH AND
PUBLICATIONS. TO POORLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE WENT THROUGH
AND TO PREVENT THE NEXT
EPIDEMIC OR PANDEMIC IS. VERY.
VERY NECESSARY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU DR BAY.
EIGHTEEN T. MA THE SECOND
WITNESS COLIN AND THEN. IS DR
VOHRA THE FRESH SNOW COUNTY
ANTRIM PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR.
DR VOHRA PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YOU HAVE A SOME YOU. C. DO NOT
SHOW HIM ONLINE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THAT THANK YOU EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR WILL THEN GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THE FRONT ORIN
THE GALLERY SCENE NINE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY AND SEE NINE. ANY
TWEETERS IN THE ON THE FLOOR OR
IN THE BACK OF THE GALLERY
SCENE NINE WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR EITHER ANY WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT. IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FIVE THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
NEXT ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. OF S. B. FOUR FIFTY
THREE. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE- IN THE QUEUE.
IF YOU IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR FIFTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND THERE ARE NO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME IN ANY WITH ANY TWEETERS
ON THE PHONE NUMBER IN THE
QUEUE. AND ANY TRAINERS OF S.
B. FOUR FIFTY THREE MY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE
WE GATHER THAT NUMBER. AGAIN
WE'RE AN SP. FOUR FIFTY THREE.
ONE MOMENT. AGAIN WE'RE ON THE-
S. B. FOUR FIFTY THREE FOR ANY
CLEANERS THAT ARE ON YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
HELLO THIS IS MERRY MORE
ALIGNED WITH THE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL- WE
WILL BE TAKING A LOOK AT THE
NEW AMENDMENTS BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE- DIRECTION THAT
THE BILL IS GOING IN. TO ENSURE
THAT MORE CAN'T CAMPUSES CAN
APPLY FOR THE POTENTIAL PLAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER TRAINERS ON THE
MONITOR IN THE QUEUE. THERE IS
NO ONE FURTHER IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU GOING TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
DOCTOR RUMBULA A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW- LIKE TO
CHOI. THANK YOU CHAIR AND-
SENATOR WITHOUT TONE THANK YOU
FOR INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
BILL IN LIGHT OFF ALL- TERRIBLE
RECORDED NINETEEN- WE HAVE-
EXPERIENCE INDUSTRIAL LAW- NOT
COMPLETELY- OUT OF- NO CONTROL-
UNDER CONTROL- SO YOU STYLE
BREACHING BIOSECURITY AND THE
AND MERGING. INFECTIONS
INFECTIOUS DISEASE OF FUND IS-
EXCELLENT IDEA- SO THAT WE- DO
A SERIOUS RESEARCH AND TO
PREVENT ANY- SUCH. INFECTION
THAT WE- ARE UNDER- THE
PRESIDENT THROUGH THE NOT GOING
ON AND- OF BEING AFFECTED- SO
IN THAT- THIS IS- ENCOURAGING-
NOT ONLY UP NOW FEDERAL FUNDED
WHAT THE LOCAL AND A PRIVATE
FUNDS SO ONCE THAT OF- OUR
SYSTEM IS ESTABLISHED OF A I'M
SURE THERE WILL BE- GREAT TO
SUPPORT ALL OF. THIS OF A FUNDA.
AND THE CSU- IS- WHAT I'M
READING MOSTLY- CSU SYSTEM SO.
BUT I WONDER WHAT THE I'M ALL
FOR LOOKING OR NOT- UC SYSTEM
YES- NOT TO MENTION THAT HERE.
WAS THERE ANY REASON WHY IS WAS
THE- ANY SEPARATE STUFF- OF
FUNDING MECHANISM SET UP FOR
UC'S CENTER THIS IS THE FOR THE
FIRST TIME FOR ME CSU SYSTEMS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND
IF I MAY ADD TO THE CHAIR. YES
UP TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION OF
WHY NOT UC AND CSU AND REALLY
IT'S ABOUT EQUITY ACTUALLY UC
DAVIS ALREADY HAS- BIOSECURITY
RESEARCH THAT THEY DO THAT THE
FOCUS ON WILDLIFE- FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE REASON
WHY THERE IS A FOCUS ON ON AND
AGRICULTURE AND AGRICULTURAL
REGIONS AND ALSO- THE CSU THAT
ARE FOCUSED OR THAT ARE STE YOU
KNOW- IN THOSE REGIONS. IS
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF WORD
INFECTIOUS DISEASES COME FROM.
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF. DON'T
LIKE IT I BELIEVE UNCERTAINTY
AS TO HOW KALRA NINETEEN CAME
ABOUT I MEAN IT THERE'S AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT CAME
FROM- FROM AN ANIMAL RIGHT AND
SO. WE REALLY GOT A LOOK AT
THOSE THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
PROVIDE AN EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS AND
THOSE COMMUNITIES TO DO
RESEARCH ABOUT WHAT IMPACTS
THEM AS WELL AND SO IT'S REALLY
MORE OF AN EQUITY ISSUE- NOT SO
MUCH OF. YOU KNOW LEAVING AT A
PARTICULAR A SYSTEM OUT- I
THINK THIS WILL BRING A
BALANCED APPROACH TO OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND REALLY-
WHAT THE CLIMATE CHANGING WORLD
IT NEEDS TO BE KIND OF AN LL
HANDS ON DECK WHEN IT COMES TO
SOLUTIONS AND TO REALLY HAVE A
TRUE UNDERSTANDING OF DISEASES-
SUCH AS THAT YOU KNOW THE
EXAMPLE WAS GIVEN EARLIER ON
VALLEY FEVER BY DOCTOR BAINES.
VALLEY FEVER FOR THE MOST PART
HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
SPECIFIC TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT THE YOUR
VALLEY FEVER MAY NOT BE YOU
KNOW MAY NOT BE THE NEXT
PANDEMIC HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES WELL WE GOT A STUDY THAT
RIGHT WE GOTTA MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE INVESTED IN AND WE HAVE
A DEDICATED CENTER AND RESEARCH
TO THAT- AND NOBODY'S GOING TO
KNOW IT BETTER THAN PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THIRTY EIGHT SPECIFIC BUT IT'S
ALSO LIKE I SAID IT'S AN
EQUITY- IT'S ABOUT HAVING A-
THAT EQUITY THROUGHOUT THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND RESEARCH.
THANK YOU DR WEBER. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THIS- FOR THIS BILL
AND I'M JUST ASING FOR A POINT
OF CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I HAD.
ASKED MY STAFF WITH THEM A
QUESTION ABOUT THIS BILL IN
TERMS OF WHICH SCHOOLS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR FINDING CELL ARE
YOU STATING THAT IT'S ONLY SEE
ISSUES WITHIN A CERTAIN REGION.
SO IT'S AT THE C. ISSUES THAT
ARE WITHIN THE AGRICULTURAL
INSTITUTE. OR UNDER THE-
AGRICULTURAL THE CSU
AGRICULTURAL INSTITUTE WITH
MULTIPLE CAMPUSES I THINK
THERE'S ABOUT. US SIX OF THEM.
DEFENDER I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
NUMBER OF WHAT PARTICULAR C.
ISSUES- BUT I CAN'T BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO YOU. AND THOSE
ARE THE ONES THAT THE CSU
CURRENTLY HAS AS- WITHIN THAT A
PARTICULAR INSTITUTE. I THINK
SENATOR TRIAL MY STAFF WILL
GIVE YOU THE LIST THERE AND DR
WEBBER. ON BESIDES THE LISTS
THAT SENATOR TYLENOL HAS- THERE
COULD BE ADDITIONAL C. ISSUES
ADDED. YOU CAN WOULD YOU WANT
TO SHARE THE LIST YES OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AGRICULTURAL RESEARCH INSTITUTE
INSTITUTE- HAS IT INCLUDES- CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY CHICO CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY FRESNO CAT CAL
STEEP THE POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITY POMONA SELES OBISPO
AND HUMBLE. AND MONTEREY BAY
AND OTHERS SEE ISSUES IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING COULD BE ADDED. I
TO THAT ASSOCIATION OR TO THAT-
UMBRELLA GROUP THAT IS CORRECT
I MEAN THIS IS A BILL THAT'S
GONNA GET SOMETHING GOING AND-
WITHIN THE CSU- BUT IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT IT'S GOING TO EXCLUDE
OTHER CAMPUSES EIGHT THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
CSU CAMPUSES INCLUDED WITHIN
THIS. THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT
POSSIBILITY BECAUSE LIKE YOU
SAID WE WANT- THE BEST RESEARCH
WE WANT THESE THINGS DISCOVERED
QUICKLY. AND EVEN IF IT MEANS
THAT IT HAPPENS TO BE IN AN
AREA THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY
THE ORIGIN. RIGHT WE'VE GOT
EBOLA AND BUT WE'RE STARTING AT
AROUND THE WORLD NOT
NECESSARILY JUST IN THE HOT
SPOT- YOU KNOW WE DIDN'T GET
THROUGH OR NOT GETTING THROUGH
THIS PANDEMIC BY JUST FOCUSING
ON EVERYTHING AND TRYING TO THE
TECHNOLOGY FOR COVERT OR SARS
TO SOUTH. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THAT WE DON'T JUST LIMIT OUR
POSSIBILITY. COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND EQUITY- BUT WE
SHOULD ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE. ALLOWING FOR- THE BEST AND
THE BRIGHTEST TO COME OUT OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO SO THAT
WE DON'T GO THROUGH SOMETHING
LIKE THIS AGAIN SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANDI WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE WITH YOU AND THAT'S PART
OF THE REASON THE PURPOSE OF
THIS. PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. AT TEN. AND TWO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THE
LEAD THE LIST OF CAMPUSES ARE
ON PAGE FIVE AND SIX OF THE
ANALYSIS. SO WE HAD A MOTION BY
DOCTOR RUMBLE- SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW- SENATOR
TODD WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SODA THANK
THE SENATOR FOR DILIGENTLY
WORKING WITH MYSELF AND MY
STAFF- TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AND APPRECIATE. YOUR IN TWO
BIO SECURITY AS IT RELATES TO
AGRICULTURE AND YOUR DESIRE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE A LEADER. IN
DISEASE PREVENTION RESEARCH. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AS
AMENDED AND LOOK FORWARD TO
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS ON WAY
TO ASSIST RESEARCHERS ON
PREVENTING NEW AND EXISTING.
EMERGING DISEASES. SO THE
MOTION BEFORE US IS DO PASSES
AMENDMENT TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I SAW A- CHOI
I'D ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM. BLOOM I GABRIEL GABRIEL
I IRWIN IRWIN I HIGHLY KILEY II
LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I CHEN. CHEN
I WEBER. WEBER ON THE VOTE IS
TWELVE ZERO. VOTERS TWELVE ZERO
YOUR BILL IS OUT AND WE DON'T
HAVE ANY ABSENT MEMBERS PRESS.
YEAH OKAY TWELVE ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU SENATOR- TADA.
OUR LAST BILL IS FILE ITEM SIX
S. B. EIGHT ZERO TWO. SENATOR
REID. WELCOME. AND YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
SB EIGHT OH TWO CURRENTLY MAKES
VARIOUS TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION ACT ADMINISTERED BY
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. THIS
IS A SUNSET BILL FOR THE BUREAU
AND STEMS FROM OUR WORK TO
COLLECTIVELY DETERMINE THE BEST
PATH FORWARD TO ENSURE STUDENT
SUCCESS AND QUALITY EDUCATION
WHILE RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR
APPROPRIATE. TRANSPARENT
REGULATION OF THE PROGRAMS
OFFERING TRAINING AND EDUCATION
TO MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
MISTER I'VE NOTED THE AREAS FOR
DISCUSSION AND THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU THE BUREAU OF
THE SCHOOLS STUDENTS ON THESE
ISSUES THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
AND OTHERS AS THIS BILL TAKE
SHAPE THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
AND MAKE SURE. THAT IT YIELDS
OUR SHARED GOALS OF AFFORDABLE
AND MEANINGFUL EDUCATION FOR
ALL AT THE APPROPRIATE POINT IN
TIME I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR REID. WE WILL
NOW GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT. ANY
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT. THERE
ARE. SO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE GALLERY IF YOU WOULD STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR FILIATION AND
POSITION. CHAIR MEDINA MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ANGELA PERRY I'M AN ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND ADVOCACY
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH TWO
AND THE RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE
BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
HAD A LASTING AND IN EQUITABLE
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S LABOR
MARKET WHICH UNFORTUNATELY
COMES ON THE HEELS OF A LONG
PERIOD OF DE REGULATION OF FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. FOLLOWING THE
GREAT RECESSION THE OVERLAP OF
AN ECONOMIC CRISIS AND THE
LACKS POSTSECONDARY REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT LED TO A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
ENROLLMENT AT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES AS PREDATORY PROGRAMS
TARGETED VULNERABLE AND
HISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
INDIVIDUALS. WITH AGGRESSIVE
RECRUITING EFFORTS. WORRYINGLY
WE ARE SEEING SIMILAR TRENDS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY MAKING THE
BUREAU'S WORK MORE ESSENTIAL
THAN EVER AS THE STATE RECOVERS
FROM THE PANDEMIC. A WELL
FUNCTIONING BUREAU IS VITAL TO
ENSURING STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO EQUITABLE QUALITY EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA. TKS AND THIRTEEN
OTHER PARTNERS RECENTLY
SUBMITTED COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT OH TWO AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WOULD FURTHER STRENGTHEN BUREAU
FUNCTION WHICH WE HOPE TO SEE
INCORPORATED INTO THE BILL
INCLUDING. ONE BY EMPOWERING
THE BUREAU TO CREATE MINIMUM
OPERATING STANDARDS TO EVALUATE
INSTITUTIONS. TO BY EVALUATING
THE BY ENABLING THE BUREAU TO
COLLECT BETTER DATA TO INFORM
THOSE STANDARDS. THREE BY
CREATING SURETY BOND
REQUIREMENT TO COVER THE COST
OF UNEXPECTED SCHOOL CLOSURES
AND FOR BY GIVING THE BUREAU
MORE DISCRETION ON
INSTITUTIONAL APPROVAL. HOWEVER
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS TO
ENSURE THE CONTINUATION OF A
SUFFICIENTLY FUNDED STABLE
BUREAU WITH THE CAPACITY AND AT
THE WORD HE NEEDED TO PROTECT
STUDENTS. THE BUREAU MUST BE RE
AUTHORIZED IN THE SUNSET DATE
SHOULD BE EXTENDED FOR A FULL-TERM OF AT LEAST FIVE YEARS TO
ALLOW THE BUREAU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FOCUS ON ITS
PRIMARY CHARGE. OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION. WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND HOPE TO
SEE THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
INCORPORATED MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ANY ANY WITNESSES. IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE BACK. ANY
TWEETERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND TO SENATOR ROTH
MY NAME IS DEBBIE COCHRAN I AM
THE BUREAU CHIEF FOR THE BUREAU
FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION I'M HERE AS A TWEENER
BECAUSE WE DON'T OFFICIALLY AT
THE BUREAU HAVE A POSITION BUT
I DID WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THESE ISSUES AND
TO ALSO LET YOU KNOW THAT WE
HAVE STAFF OF BOTH THE BUREAU
AND DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS HERE IN CASE OUR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT ARISE.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO INTRODUCE MYSELF TO
YOU- I WAS HONORED TO HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED TO THIS YEAR OF CHIEF
POSITION BACK IN MARCH WAS
SWORN IN IN APRIL- BUT ACTUALLY
THE HIGHER EDUCATION EQUITABLE
AFFORDABLE HIGHER EDUCATION HAS
BEEN THE PRIORITY OF MY COOKING
TIRE CAREER IN FACT THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND MEMBER MANY OF
YOUR INDIVIDUAL OFFICES. ON
ISSUES RELATED TO THE BUREAU
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM AND MANY
MORE ISSUES OF HIGHER EDUCATION
IMPORTANCE SO I JUST WANTED TO
AGAIN TAKE THAT MOMENT TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF- TELL YOU HOW
MUCH I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL TO
REINSTITUTING SURE THE
REAUTHORIZATION OF THE BUREAU
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
TWEETERS. THE CITY NINE WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. BURKE IN THE QUEUE
CARE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT ZERO TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
SUPPORT. WE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MANY RODRIGUEZ
ON BEHALF EDUCATION TRUST ONCE
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IN THE LINE OR SOME OF THE
COMMENTS FROM TEACHERS ON THE
COALITION THIRTEEN
ORGANIZATIONS THANK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THE MODERATOR THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT ZERO TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO APPEAR IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION ACCU THIS
TIME. MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WHO ARE TWEETERS. ANY
TRADER FOR SB EIGHT ZERO TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT
ONE AND THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE TO QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SHARE THIS IS MATT
BACK REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY SCHOOLS
I APPRECIATE THE TWENTY ONE
CATEGORY- WE DO SUPPORT THE
EXTENSION OF THE BUREAU AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
CHAIRMAN PROF AND ALL THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO DO THAT-
HOWEVER THERE ARE FEW CONCERNS
WE DO HAVE- ONE WITHIN THE
EXISTING- BILL IMPRINTS. AND
ALLOW. ZERO TWO SYSTEM THE OVER.
WHICH SCHOOLS LIKE FOR PUT.
HARM WE FIND THAT A PROVISION
CONCERNING AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ON
THAT. ALSO DENOUNCED BUT WHAT
IS THE NUMBER OF POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS. WHAT WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS THAT WITH SOME OF
THOSE CONCEPT- MOST NOTABLY
THERE IS THE PROPOSAL. THAT HAS
BEEN LINGERING ALL SESSION-
OVER 40% THE INCREASE OF THE
MINIMUM WITH MORE FOR SOME
INSTITUTIONS WHICH CLEARLY
RAISES CONCERNED. INHERENT
PROPERTIES THAT WERE-
DRASTICALLY INCREASE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN. ALSO CALLED FOR A
SHIRT HE BOND THAT WHICH WILL
RANGE A NUMBER OF OTHER
CONCERNS. AND THEN IT JUST
TURNED WILL ALLOW FOR- SOME OF
THE SUGGESTIONS. BUT ACTUALLY
HAD EXTENSIVE. WHAT THE BILL
YOU CAN BUREAU AT A TIME WHEN
THEY'RE STRUCK- RIGHT NOW- TO
MAKE THEIR HOLE. AN INMATE IN
ME SO CERTAINLY HAVE AN OF
COULD- AND WELL BUT AGAIN WE DO
SUPPORT THE EXTENSION OF THE
GIRLS WANT TO MAKE THAT CRYSTAL
CLEAR AND AGAIN WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF A
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER SHARE MEMBERS SCOTT
GOVERNOR BEHALF WITH UNIVERSITY
OF PHOENIX- WE ALSO SUPPORT
EXTENDING THE BUREAU WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR INSTITUTIONS
AND STUDENTS ALIKE- LIKE MR
BACK. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS WITH THE SUGGESTIONS
IN PARTICULAR THE MINIMUM
OPERATING STANDARDS. WHICH
WOULD REPRESENT THE SINGLE
LARGEST EXPANSION OF THE
BUREAU'S RESPONSIBILITIES- THAT
I CAN REMEMBER HAVING WORKED IN
THIS ISSUE FOR TWENTY YEARS. SO
ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
SHOULD CERTAINLY BE HELD OFF
UNTIL NEXT YEAR OVER THE
INTERIM- BUT FOR NOW WE DO
ENDORSE THE BUREAU MOVING
FORWARD. THANK ANY ANY OTHER
YOU ANYWAY. I'M SORRY I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU GOING TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. C. NINE
SET. WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR
CHOI. SECOND BY DOCTOR RUMBULA
CENTER ROCK WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. MISTER THANK YOU THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND
AGAIN THANK YOU SENATOR ROB FOR
BRINGING THE MEASURE FORWARD
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
THE VARIOUS COMMITTEES AND
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER WORKING WITH
YOU REGARDING THE SUNSET
EXTENSION OF THE BUREAU PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION THAT A
MOTION BY DOCTOR CHOICE A
SECOND BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
ARAMBULA MADAM SECRETARY VIEWED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI. CHOI I
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL GABRIEL I
IRWIN- WHEN I KILEY KILEY II
LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I CHAN CHAN I
WEBER. WEBER II VOTERS TWELVE
ZERO TWELVE ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT SENATOR ROB THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. WE WILL NOW O
BACK- TO BILLS THAT WE HAD ON
CALL AT THEY ARE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KILEY KILEY I LOW LOW I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI THE VOTERS
TWELVE ZERO TWELVE ZERO THE
CONSENT- ITEMS ARE PASSED. OKAY
FILE ITEM FOR SB FIVE ONE TWO.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I KILEY KILEY I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI THE
VOTERS. TWELVE ZERO TWELVE ZERO
SB FIVE TWELVE IS OUT. FILE
ITEM FIVE SB FOUR FOUR TWO
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I KILEY KILEY
I LOW LOW I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI THE VOTERS TWELVE ZERO
TWELVE ZERO S. B. FOUR FOUR TWO
IS OUT AND THAT IS EVERYTHING
AND THAT IS EVERYTHING ALL
RIGHT. THIS IS OUR LAST HEARING
AND SINCE IT'S OUR LAST HEARING
ON LIKE TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE
TO THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE STAFF
THE RULES COMMITTEE STAFF. THE
LEGISLATIVE DATACENTER THE A.
T. AND T. MODERATOR ALL WHO
ENSURED THIS HEARING COULD TAKE
PLACE I ESPECIALLY WISH TO
THANK MY COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR HARD WORK COMMITMENT
AND DEDICATION. THE COMMITTEE
OF HIGHER EDUCATION IS A JERK
THANK YOU ALL.